JAMES MILIUS: My
name is James Milius.
I'm a senior here at
Hillsdale, originally
from Beaverton, Oregon.
I'm studying philosophy
and sociology.
And I'm here to introduce
our speaker for tonight.
Dr. Frank Dikotter is
Chairman and Professor
of Humanities at the
University of Hong Kong
and Senior Fellow at
the Hoover Institution.
Previously, he
taught at the School
of Oriental and African
Studies, University of London,
from which he earned his PhD.
He has written numerous books,
including The Discourse of Race
in Modern China, China Before
Mao: The Age of Openness,
and Crime, Punishment and
the Prison in Modern China.
Dr. Dikotter is the author of
People's Trilogy, a work that
documents the
impact of Communism
on the lives of ordinary
people in China.
The first volume,
Mao's Great Famine,
won the 2011 Samuel Jonsson
Prize for non-fiction.
The second, The
Tragedy of Liberation,
was shortlisted for the
Orwell Prize in 2014.
The final installment,
The Cultural Revolution,
was shortlisted for the PEN
Hessell-Tiltman Prize in 2017.
Would you please join me in
welcoming Dr. Frank Dikotter?
[APPLAUSE]
FRANK DIKOTTER: Good evening.
Thank you for coming.
I'm delighted to be here,
a little jet lagged.
I arrived from London yesterday.
I got up at 5:00 in the morning.
I couldn't wait any longer.
So at 7:00, I went outside
and walked around the campus.
So here's a fact.
There's nobody to be seen in
Hillsdale on a Sunday morning
at 7:00.
Not a soul.
I did see a few chaps--
one of them is called George--
and a very distinguished
lady called Maggie.
Now if 30 years
ago, somebody would
have asked Margaret
Thatcher, what
is the Organization Department
in the People's Republic
of China?
Or for that matter, the
Organization Bureau,
or [RUSSIAN],, as the
Russians used to say--
I think she would have frowned.
I think she would
have said, young man,
back you go to Communism 101.
About a month ago, at
the Hoover Institution,
I was asked to speak to 20
senior Congressional Fellows,
all very smart, all
quite distinguished.
I asked them, do you know what
the Organization Department
is in the People's
Republic of China?
Not a single one of
them knew what that was.
So understanding China is
the theme of this conference.
If you do not know what an
organization department is,
you do not understand China.
It's as simple as that.
If you do know, you
don't have to stay.
But there's good news.
At the end of my talk,
you will know what it is,
and I hope you will have a
better idea of the entity
that we are dealing with.
My brief is to talk about
the Chinese Revolution, which
starts in 1949.
I will focus mainly on
the 30 years under Mao,
but I will also
spend about eight,
nine minutes talking about
China over the last 40 years,
bringing it up to date.
Now like the Organization
Department, or the [RUSSIAN],,
everything invariably
starts in the Soviet Union.
In this case, it
starts with Stalin.
No Stalin, no Mao.
It's as simple as that.
On the 6th of August,
1945, Hiroshima in Japan
is erased in a blinding
flash of light.
Two days later, Stalin sends a
million men across the border
from Siberia into Manchuria,
the industrial powerhouse
of China to the
north of Beijing.
They are on their
way to Korea, where
they wait for the American
allies along the 38th parallel.
Japan surrenders.
The Russians don't leave.
They hand over North
Korea to Kim Il-Sung
and the countryside
in Manchuria to
the Chinese Communist
leader, Mao Tse Tung.
They help him transform
his ragtag army
of guerrilla fighters into a
formidable fighting machine.
The Russians establish
16 military institutions,
including Air Force, artillery,
and engineering schools.
Some Chinese officers
go all the way
to Moscow for advanced training.
Logistical aid arrives
by rail and by sea.
In North Korea alone,
some 2,000 wagon loads
are allocated to the task.
The Americans, on
the other hand,
impose an arms embargo on the
wartime ally, Chiang Kai-shek,
and the nationalists.
Chiang Kai-shek loses
battle after battle
in a war of attrition
in Manchuria.
By 1948, the Communists
feel strong enough
to start surrounding
cities and blockading them.
In the case of Changchun, Lin
Biao, one of Mao's generals,
commands the city
to be transformed
into a city of death.
His troops establish a perimeter
around Changchun, trenches
four meters deep, and
do not allow anyone
to leave for five months.
160,000 ordinary people
are starved to death.
[INAUDIBLE],, a lieutenant with
the Chinese Communist Army,
noted later on that Hiroshima
and Changchun were the same.
Hiroshima took nine seconds.
Changchun took five months.
The casualties were
roughly the same.
Other cities surrender,
unwilling to undergo
the same fate.
By the end of 1949, Chiang
Kai-shek and the Nationalists
flee to Taiwan.
The red flag goes up over the
Forbidden City in Beijing.
It is called
liberation, a term that
brings to mind jubilant crowds
who welcomed the liberators.
But liberation is the result
of a long and brutal war
of conquest.
Power, Mao used to say, power
comes from the barrel of a gun.
But Mao knew very well that the
People's Liberation Army could
only keep power for so long.
What was required
was a revolution,
the overthrow of the old order.
And it came in the guise of
a campaign for land reform.
It had very little
to do with the land.
It had everything
to do with power.
Communist work teams
fanned out into villages
and polarized closely
knit communities
into a majority obliged to
denounce a minority of victims,
frequently the democratically
elected village leaders.
Some villages did
this with relish,
but a great many had no choice
because those who refused
would be denounced in turn.
The victims were
denounced as landlords,
tyrants, evil gentry,
humiliated, beaten,
sometimes killed, their assets
distributed to the crowd.
So in effect, ordinary
people entered a pact
sealed in blood with the party.
All of them had
blood on their hands.
All of them had participated
in the persecution
of a small number of victims.
They did not want
Chiang Kai-shek
and the Nationalist
party to return.
This is land reform.
A year later, in October,
1950, Chairman Mao
decided that it was
time to eliminate
all the enemies standing in
the path of the revolution--
spies, bandits, counter
revolutionaries.
He issued a killing quota
of one per thousand.
Go out, kill one per thousand.
In many parts of
China, local cadres--
some pronounce this as cadres--
local cadres, or
Communist Party members,
tried to vie with
each other and show
their revolutionary
determination
so that this quota
doubled or trebled.
In the south, some of
these party activists
used the campaign of
terror to settle accounts
with the local population
who had resisted
the arrival of the Communists.
Entire villages were razed.
In some cases, schoolchildren
as young as six
were accused of spying
for the Nationalists.
Sometimes a few
prisoners were simply
taken out and shot
for a local official
to meet his killing quota
of one per thousand.
People were supposed to be
shot in public and rallies
taking place in stadiums,
which all had to witness.
But in many cases,
they were taken
deep into forests, along
rivers, near ravines,
alone or in batches.
About 1.5 to two million
people were eliminated,
coming on top of the two million
people denounced as landlords
during so-called land reform.
So by now we're counting in the
four to five million victims.
Many more were
stigmatized for life
and disappeared into a
sprawling prison system
across the country.
To paraphrase Simon
Schama, the historian
of the French Revolution,
violence was the revolution.
But of course, violence had
trusted companions, namely
fear and intimidation.
People across the
realm were asked
to transform
themselves into what
the party called new people.
They had to go back to school
in factories and offices
and learn the right answers,
learn the right ideas,
learn how to shout the
right slogans, to confess,
account for their
past activities,
demonstrate their
loyalty to the party,
possibly denounce colleagues,
neighbors, family members.
But of course, there's more than
just violence and intimidation.
The history of
revolution in China
is also a history of promises
made and promises broken.
Mao, like Lenin
and the Bolsheviks,
promised every disaffected
group what they wanted most--
more land for the
villages, freedom
of speech for intellectuals,
independence for minorities,
protection of private
property for entrepreneurs,
better working conditions
for the workers.
One by one, these
promises were destroyed
as Mao imposed a harsh
Stalinist system on the country.
One by one, the enemies
were eliminated.
It started first with the
counter revolutionaries
at the height of this
campaign of terror
that I just described.
But then the campaign moved
on to target former government
servants who had been
promised lenient treatment
by the Communists in 1949 but
were eliminated or targeted
in 1952.
And after that, the business
community was brought to heel.
Every organization outside
of the organization
of the Communist Party
of China was eliminated--
religious communities,
philanthropic associations,
powerful chambers of
commerce, labor unions,
all of them eliminated
and replaced by the party.
By 1956, all enterprises
were nationalized
and became functions
of the state.
If you had been running a
corner shop in Shanghai,
then you would be
pleading with the party
to be allowed to continue
to work as a state employee.
The land was taken back
from all the villagers, who
lost their freedom of movement.
By 1956, they had
to sell the grain
they produced to the state
at state-mandated prices.
But something happened in
1956 that upset the chairman.
His model, Stalin, had
died three years earlier.
In February, 1956, his
successor, Nikita Khrushchev,
in a secret speech that very
much shook the Socialist camp
to its core, denounced
Stalin, his reign and terror
and a cult of personality.
Mao viewed it as
a personal attack.
He, after all, was
China's Stalin.
His answer was to come
up with a great leap
forward from socialism into
communism that would somehow
leave the Soviet Union behind.
His hope was to upstage
Nikita Khrushchev
and become the leader
of the Socialist camp.
Hundreds of millions of ordinary
people in the countryside
were herded into
giant collectives
called people's communes.
These people's
communes were modeled
on the army with
collective canteens,
collective dormitories.
By transforming every man and
every woman in the countryside
into a foot soldier,
and a giant army
to be deployed day and night
to transform the economy,
Mao thought that he could
catapult his country
past the Soviet Union.
But the Great Leap
Forward was a disaster.
It led to literally
tens of millions
of people being starved,
beaten, worked to death.
Villagers had no
incentive to work.
The land was no longer theirs.
Their tools, utensils,
even pots and pans
had all been confiscated.
They were literally bonded
servants of the state,
at the back and call
of local cadres.
They earned work points to be
exchanged for food in canteens.
But the cadres,
on the other hand,
had to whip up the workforce
in one relentless drive
after the other.
Produce more fertilizer,
more grain, more steel
from backyard furnaces.
They had to whip
up the workforce.
So the scope and
degree of coercion
had to be constantly expanded,
resulting in a mounting
spiral of violence.
In order to get impoverished,
famished people to work,
they were pummeled, beaten,
whipped, some of them tied up,
thrown into ponds,
covered in excrement,
branded with sizzling tools,
occasionally buried alive.
The most important tool at
the disposal of party cadres
to punish people who didn't
work hard enough was food.
Food was used as a weapon.
In many parts of
the country, those
who were too weak
or too old to work
were deliberately
banned from the canteens
and allowed to starve to death.
What I'm trying to say is
that people didn't simply
starve to death.
They were starved to death.
The Great Leap Forward came to
an end in 1962 at great cost.
And it damaged the
standing of Mao Tse Tung
He wondered whether somebody
might destroy his legacy,
as had happened with Stalin.
Would there be a Chinese
Kruschev to denounce him,
even as he was still alive?
And most of all, how
would Chairman Mao
be able to spot the
Chinese Kruschev,
since Stalin himself had
been unable to identify
his own nemesis and had
even promoted Kruschev
through the ranks of the party?
Mao's response was the
Cultural Revolution.
He prepared it very carefully.
It began in 1966,
four years later.
The Cultural
Revolution was designed
to be an attack on feudal,
bourgeois, capitalist culture
that Mao believed was a
threat to Communist ideology.
But Mao also used the
Cultural Revolution
to unleash ordinary people
and punish all those
inside the party
hierarchy who had ever
expressed any doubt about him
and the Great Leap Forward.
First, students in
the summer of 1966
were allowed to
criticize their teachers.
They rapidly became Red
Guards and also attacked
what they refer to
as the old rules,
burning books, vandalizing
churches, tearing down temples,
attacking any sign of the past.
In Shanghai alone they raided
a quarter of a million homes,
taking away ordinary
books, family photographs,
but also antique bronzes, rare
paintings, all of it destroyed.
They also attacked
people they suspected
were enemies of the Revolution.
In Beijing alone, in
September, 1966, 1,700
of them were killed, a few
thousand petrol and set alight,
a number also electrocuted.
In the autumn of
1966, Mao went further
and allowed ordinary people
to criticize ranking party
members, which they did.
But people, of
course, became divided
over who the true enemies of
the Cultural Revolution were,
so they started
fighting each other.
Then the army intervened,
as Mao asked them to support
the true proletarian left.
But different
officers in the Army
weren't quite sure, either, who
they should fight, and ended up
fighting each other
in the streets.
The country was on the
very edge of civil war.
This episode comes
to an end in 1968,
as so-called new Revolutionary
Party committees appear.
They represent a
command structure
that Mao relished,
top to bottom,
one man in every place,
the military structure.
And these so-called
Revolutionary Party committees
were heavily
dominated by the Army,
with soldiers overseeing
factories, schools, offices.
They turned China
into a Garrison state.
Their first act was to punish
all the students and Red Guards
who had taken the
chairman at his word,
sending literally
millions of them
to the countryside to be
re-educated by the peasants.
Other purges followed.
In Shanghai, anyone with
a foreign link in the past
was seen to be suspect.
170,000 people were
harassed, thousands
killed or committing suicide.
In Guangdong Province
alone, the province
just across the border from Hong
Kong, where I work and live,
one estimate puts the
body count at 40,000.
But of course, Mao was
suspicious of everyone,
and also the army that
now run the country.
In September, 1971, Lin
Biao, the very man who
had besieged Changchun
in Manchuria in 1948,
conveniently died
in a plane accident.
Now the army was purged in turn.
At this point, in 1971, ordinary
people in the countryside
realize that the Cultural
Revolution has badly damaged
the Communist Party of China.
The credibility of communism
was destroyed by the Great Leap
Forward and the famine, but
the organization of the party
was undermined by the
Cultural Revolution.
Ordinary people,
villagers, start
what I refer to as
a silent revolution.
Even before Mao dies,
they take back the land.
They take back their tools.
They open black markets.
They operate
underground factories.
They return to the past.
And there's not a lot the
party can do about it.
No party would have
tolerated open confrontation.
But these are
millions and millions
of daily acts of
resistance as people
wrenched away from the state
very basic economic freedoms.
Mao dies in 1976.
Three years later, a man
referred to as Deng Xiaoping
take his place.
Short, nasty little man.
He had purged
intellectuals in 1957,
and he would do the same
again and again and again.
But Deng Xiaoping
at first attempted
to force villagers to go back
to the people's communes.
He soon realized that he
didn't have the clout to do it.
So he's wise enough to step
back and allow ordinary people
to just get on with
their economic business.
The people's communes
collapsed in 1982.
From here onwards, very
basic economic freedoms
produce economic growth.
That economic growth is used
by the party to rebuild itself.
Deng Xiaoping and
his followers are
determined to allow
some economic leniency,
but equally
determined to suppress
every political aspiration.
There are many twists
and turns in this story,
not least the massacre around
Tiananmen Square in June 1989.
But overall, human
ingenuity managed
to thrive despite the
constraints of the one party
state.
If you have acclaimed what has
happened since 1979 as nothing
short of an economic
miracle, well,
if you look at the gross
domestic product per capita
according to the
International Monetary Fund,
China ranked number 126 in 1980.
By the time the tanks move
into Tiananmen Square,
it has moved up to
121, where it remains
until the end of
the 20th century,
only to increase by
five ranks up to 2007.
At that point, it is just
below Zimbabwe under Mugabe.
He's gone.
Thank God for that.
And just below Zimbabwe,
just above Turkmenistan.
That's where China is in 2007.
It is true that after
the crisis in 2008,
it jumps all the
way up from 116,
jumps all the way up to 76.
Quite an achievement.
In fact, for anyone who
has visited China 10,
15, 20 years ago, it seems as
if it is a different country.
And indeed, one of the
accomplishments of the regime
today is to have
distanced itself
so successfully from the
Mao era that it doesn't even
appear to exist.
There are no monuments to
the victims of the Cultural
Revolution, no memorials
for the tens of millions who
died during Mao's Great Famine.
But on the other hand,
skyscrapers everywhere,
bullet trains, modern
airports, modern railways,
roses along the highways.
It's almost like a
paradise, isn't it?
But when you scratch that
shimmering surface, what
you will discover underneath
are the iron underpinnings
of the one party state.
The very institutions put
in place by Mao after 1949
have been spruced up.
There is, for instance,
the Propaganda
Department, which hasn't
changed its function since Mao,
although today, conveniently,
it is translated officially
into English as the
Publicity Department.
Then there is the
Ministry of Security
and the Ministry of State
Security, two giants that
reach out into every
single household.
There's the Bureau
of Statistics that
produced the numbers required
to portray the Great Leap
Forward as a miracle.
And the Bureau of
Statistics continues
to produce the figures
that the party demands.
And then, of course, there is
the Organization Department
that anyone familiar
with communist regimes
will immediately
identify as the one that
is responsible for appointing
leading party members to shadow
every government institution.
If Hillsdale were to be
taken over by the Communist
Party of China
tomorrow, God forbid,
it would mean that
the mayor of Hillsdale
is appointed by the
Organization Department.
The president of
Hillsdale College
is appointed by the
Organization Department.
The Organization Department
will appoint a party secretary
to every department and
decide who teaches what,
what should be researched,
and who should be invited.
My feeling is I
would not be welcome.
After 1949, Mao destroyed
all organizations outside
of the organization of the
Communist Party of China.
He placed the
party in a position
to rob the people
of their assets.
That situation has not
fundamentally changed.
The land belongs to the state.
The banks belong to the state.
Industry belongs to the state.
Major enterprises are
controlled, directly
or indirectly, by the state.
Economists have observed
that consumption levels
tend to be low in the
People's Republic of China.
They are low because their
wealth goes to the state,
and from the state to the
party, not to ordinary people.
Well, you might object and
say, it's not communist.
They allow private property.
Really.
But every single leader
from Mao Tse Tung onwards,
including Deng Xiaoping,
has made it crystal clear
that there will not be
separation of powers,
and there is none.
There is no judicial
independence,
which means that there
is no rule of law,
which means that you cannot
defend your private property.
If you read the
Constitution, you
will find out that
what is referred
to as Socialist property
is apparently sacred,
but not so private property.
You might say, but
there are plenty
of billionaires in China.
Yes, they occasionally
disappear for a while.
They either reappear
on TV to confess
or you never see them again.
Their assets now
belong to the state,
and other billionaires
then scurry
to prove their
loyalty to the party.
In essence, despite all the
talk about reform and opening
up over the last 40
years, the Communist Party
has remained in
charge of the economy.
The commanding
heights of the economy
are controlled by the party.
You may very well
argue that there
are relative merits
to a one party state,
for instance, stability,
or at least the appearance
of stability during
economic crises,
for instance, the one in 2008.
But to think that the Chinese
Communist Party will undertake
meaningful economic or political
reform, I think, is mistaken.
Its hand is everywhere and will
not move of its own accord.
To think otherwise, to believe
that political reform will
follow economic reform, as every
American president has done
from Nixon onwards, except for
the one in Washington today,
is to engage in what I
call a China fantasy.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
Dr. Dikotter has
agreed to sign copies
of his book, Mao's Great
Famine, directly following
this session in the
Surrell Lobby outside.
And we now have time
for a few questions,
so please make your
way to the microphone
if you have a question.
And I am reminded
by our director
that students who
ask good questions
will be considered
for extra credit.
OK.
AUDIENCE: You say that--
I learned that you
are a professor
at the University of Hong Kong.
How is teaching there
with the situation that's
going on right there right now?
FRANK DIKOTTER: It's
a good question,
but I haven't taught there
the last three months.
In fact, I haven't
even been in Hong Kong.
I was at the Hoover
Institution in July and August,
and I've been in Europe since.
I was only in Hong
Kong for one day.
I was happy the
airport was open.
Having said that, I have
nothing but admiration
for the people of Hong Kong.
And I have to say I have
slightly less admiration
for the police.
I understand that
occasionally, you
might wish to use tear gas and
fire rubber bullets and club
people on the head.
But you must have a strategy.
The only result is that
these demonstrators move
from one street to another.
It seems rather pointless.
It fuels anger.
It creates more protesters,
more grievances.
What is crystal
clear is that many
of these very young people,
some of them probably
my own students, are
utterly determined
because they've seen whatever
few freedoms they have
being very gradually undermined
by the one party state
across the border.
In 1997, Hong Kong was
returned from Britain,
was a Crown colony, to the
People's Republic of China.
People's Republic
of China undertook
to not change its
institutions for 50 years
and promised free elections.
That promise has been broken.
Now those few freedoms
are being crushed.
People are upset,
and rightly so.
I have nothing but
admiration for them.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
From my limited knowledge
of Chinese history,
it seems that the regime has had
various weaknesses that you've
pointed to.
But with the recent
implementation
of their social credit system
and the massive surveillance
state that they've
built, it seems
that they would
be able to correct
a lot of these weaknesses,
and I wonder if you
might be able to speak to that.
FRANK DIKOTTER: It's important
not to overestimate your enemy.
It's important not to
underestimate him, either.
We tend to think
of dictatorships
as societies which
are beautifully
regimented from top to bottom.
The truth is, under the Nazis,
under Stalin, under Mao,
it is chaos.
Why?
Because there is never
just one dictator.
There are a million of them.
I'll be my little dictator here.
There are thousands of rules
and thousands of regulations.
They're implemented according
to the whim of the person who
happens to be in charge.
It creates chaos on the ground.
It's true to this day.
I go to China--
this year, before July, I went
virtually every second week.
There are cameras
everywhere in Shanghai.
People, we are told, will
be fined if they jaywalk.
I do it.
Everybody does it
happily, except that there
is a policeman standing
right there to stop you.
But as he stops you,
somebody else will cross.
Anarchy.
When I travel, I'm
always a little
apprehensive
because these people
at airports, railway stations--
customs is across the border
from Hong Kong into China--
are obviously unable
to read a passport.
They don't know who I am.
How do you spell my name?
It's all a great mystery.
So before we get to
this Orwellian state
where everybody's
registered and regimented,
I think China will
have a very long way
to go with one exception.
And that is, of course, the
outer realms of the empire.
The Bolsheviks inherited
the Czarist empire.
Mao inherited the Ching empire.
The boundaries are the same.
They haven't decolonized yet.
So when it comes to
Tibet and Xinjiang,
there are definitely
cameras everywhere.
And every means possible
is used to punish people.
There are more
cameras, probably,
in some villages
in Tibet than there
are textbooks for children.
These are tremendously
poor villages,
yet you will see
cameras on every street.
So in that sense, yes,
it's definitely a threat.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a quick question
regarding the Sin Kang
Kang in the inner
Mongolia and Tibet.
Sun Yat Sen, I believe
he said that one
of the reasons you couldn't
implement democracy into China
immediately was because
people weren't ready for--
sort of the country
wasn't unified yet.
So somebody had to unify the
government first, and then
allow for freedom and elections.
Is this what the People's
Republic of China
is doing with their sinicization
of the SIn Kang, Inner
Mongolia, and Tibet in order
to prevent separatist movements
once they democratize?
FRANK DIKOTTER: So
there's two questions.
One is Sun Yat Sen.
One is what happened after 1949.
Very clearly, this
is an empire that
pretends to be a nation state.
So what you see is
the same time zone,
whether you traveled to
Xinjiang or to Manchuria,
regions that are extremely
far away from each other.
There is the
imposition of Mandarin,
one standard language at the
detriment of local languages.
Everything is to do
with unification,
with the imposition of one
particular standard, one
culture, one time zone,
et cetera, et cetera.
But I wish to say something
about Sun Yat Sen.
He may very well have said that.
But the truth is that after
the empire collapsed in 1911,
China was the very
first republic in Asia.
Some 40 million people voted
in 1912, 10% of the population.
It was an electoral
representation
that was not reached
by Japan till 1928,
I think, India till 1935.
There was a huge
interest from 1912
until 1949 in
participatory democracy.
There were civil associations.
There was an attempt to
separate out powers and build up
an independent judicial system.
All too often we skip the entire
first half of the 20th century
as if Mao somehow
came from nowhere.
But the truth is that
the Republic of China,
the period from 1912
to 1949, demonstrates
that China can perfectly well
be a democratic, open, thriving
society.
And that's what we
have to bear in mind.
AUDIENCE: All right, sir.
Thank you for
coming to Hillsdale.
I appreciate you coming.
So trying to be pragmatic
here in September of 2019,
you mentioned right at
the end of your talk
about not engaging
in a China fantasy
with the current administration.
So I want to hear
your thoughts on what
we're doing right,
what we're doing wrong,
how our current
dispute with China
is likely to end, specifically
with the tariffs and the trade
war.
So I wanted to see what
your thoughts were on that.
FRANK DIKOTTER: Well, I
don't know how it will end.
I'm a historian.
I study the past,
not the future.
But you want my guess.
Well, as I pointed out at
the very end of my talk,
for the first time
you have a president
who seems to know
how to unsettle
that regime profoundly.
[APPLAUSE]
And you have
somebody who appears
to understand that the biggest
threat to your freedom,
and mine as well, comes from
the People's Republic of China
with the largest organization
on Planet Earth devoted
to crushing the very values
of freedom and democracy.
Now is the trade war the
right way of doing this?
Well, my understanding of
Adam Smith and free trade
is that we live on an island.
Now you're good at fishing.
You have five fish.
I have five coconuts every day.
We exchange.
You're wealthier, I'm wealthier.
But as I pointed out,
when Europeans buy stuff
from China, when Americans
buy stuff from China,
the theory would be that
Chinese people will buy stuff
from Europe and stuff
from the United States.
But they don't.
It's called
financial repression.
The wealth flows to the party.
Their bank accounts
belong to the state.
The state does as it sees fit
with the money of other people.
It will build these
empty airports.
empty railways.
It will build up that
mighty army it has.
So in that sense,
it's not free trade,
and it most certainly
isn't fair trade.
So again, the trade
war seems to me
to be a reasonable approach,
all the more if you study
the economy of China
since 1979 and you
realize how
extraordinarily dependent
they are on earning
foreign currency.
In the beginning, I said
everything goes back to Stalin.
We may think of
the economy today
as being utterly
different, but what
did Stalin do with
the first famine,
first Communist
famine, '29, '32, '33?
He took massive stocks of
food from the countryside
to sell it on the
international market
in order to buy the
industrial equipment needed
to modernize the Soviet Union.
He wanted foreign currency.
That's exactly what Mao did.
That's exactly what Deng did.
That's exactly what Xi does.
The only difference,
under Mao, trade
would be with the
Socialist bloc.
Under Deng, it's with
the rest of the world.
But this is a machine
devoted to making sure
that China can sell
as much as possible
at a very small margin.
There are tax rebates.
There are subsidies.
There are massive, huge
state structures behind it.
And all of that
foreign currency is
needed to keep the rest
of the country afloat.
So if you poke a hole
in that, then you
see the leaders
in Beijing scurry
because they are so incredibly
dependent on you and your US
dollars that you will
weaken them very quickly.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming out tonight.
I have a question pertaining
to the issue of Hong Kong,
and ultimately the
ideology of China.
It seems one consistent
theme throughout.
Want me to just hold it?
SPEAKER 1: I'm supposed
to hold it, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: OK, gotcha.
Yeah.
It seems like one
consistent theme
is the method doesn't matter.
The only thing that
matters is the result,
which is more power or
control over the people,
whether it be
modernisation or literally
tearing down a culture.
How, then, can the United States
defend cities like Hong Kong,
or an entire
quasi-country like Taiwan,
when the government literally
does not care about the means,
but securing what they want?
Is there any actual
strategy we can draw up,
or is it just simply
like playing checkers
back and forth?
FRANK DIKOTTER: Well, as I said,
don't overestimate your enemy.
Don't underestimate him.
We may think that
Hong Kong is just
a small city of eight
million people with its laws,
with its independent
judicial system.
And across the border
is 1.4 billion people.
They call it one
country, two systems.
Really?
Seems a little
unbalanced, doesn't it?
Hardly fair for
eight million people
to put up a fight to preserve--
not acquire new freedoms,
preserve the ones they have.
What can you do if
that 1.4 million
machine is determined
to crush Hong Kong?
Well, guess what?
Goes back to what
I said earlier on.
The wealth goes to the
party and party members.
Do you think they have any
faith in their own system?
No.
These billionaires, who
I mentioned occasionally
disappear, and their wealth,
from one day to the next,
becomes state property.
If you're smart, you have money,
you place it in Hong Kong.
There are thousands of companies
in Hong Kong from the mainland.
Some 60% of inward investment
comes from Hong Kong.
60% of outward investment
goes through Hong Kong.
It's vital.
They've tried to replicate it
with Shenzhen and Shanghai,
and they've failed
because they don't
have separation of powers.
So sometimes it just seems
like you're fighting a monster
that you can't beat.
But remember, the Soviet
Union was the same story
in the 1970s.
People would come
back from Siberia
and say, oh, these Soviets.
They're going to
overtake the world.
They've got a system
we can't beat.
They crush democracy.
But the result is a strong man.
They can do things we
simply can't get away with.
It's the lost fight.
How could you
possibly fight them?
Well, it disintegrated,
more or less,
with a bit of help from another
chap who's out there, Ronald.
He's a bit fenced off, though.
So there are many tools that you
can use to fight the one party
state, and many of these
tools actually come straight--
in Europe, in this country--
from our experience
of the Cold War.
And one approach
of the Cold War is
to have one standard
for everyone, not
a double standard.
And this is the issue.
So much knowledge about the
Soviet Union, and the moment
we talk about China, it's as
if all that knowledge just
evaporates.
Why?
Because when we used to
talk about the Soviet Union,
it was about politics,
not about culture.
Nobody in his right
mind would stand up
and say the Soviet Union is a
different culture, you know?
It's the Orthodox Church.
No, the Orthodox
Church was crushed.
Survived.
Now we talk about China.
It's the exact opposite.
It's not about politics.
It's about culture.
Read Henry Kissinger.
They're not really communists.
It's Confucian culture.
These people are wonderful.
They're not true communists.
Three presidents said this.
Roosevelt. He thought all these
are just agrarian reformers,
so let's not help
Chiang Kai-shek.
Mao Tze Tung is a good chap.
Well, a few years later they
were fighting them in Korea.
Didn't go all that well.
Nixon, Kissinger, same story.
Oh, this Confucian
culture, they're
not like the Soviet Union.
We should use them
against the Soviet Union,
allow them access
under Clinton--
under Reagan, I'm sorry to say--
allow them access to our
technology, sell them weapons,
have the students do
things we would never
do with the Soviet Union till
it collapsed in '89, 1991.
And Clinton '94 after the
Tiananmen massacre, same story.
Help them with their
economy, and they
will reform as surely as
the cart follows the ox.
Didn't happen, either.
One standard.
You sign a treaty, you
respect the treaty.
You say you will do something,
you stick to your word.
One standard for
treatment of human beings.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Are you OK
for a few more questions?
FRANK DIKOTTER: I'm happy to
go on for as long as you want.
As far as I'm concerned,
it's 2:00 in the morning, so.
AUDIENCE: I hope it
doesn't take that long.
I'm not very good at this.
About 25 some years ago,
I established a 100%
foreign owned company in China.
And about a year ago, I sold it.
And I engaged my wife's
help, who is Chinese.
I engaged a local, very
high level accountant
to advise me on how to deal
with the cash, several millions
of dollars.
And so well, maybe, you know,
buy a new car or something?
He said, oh, no, you
better not do that.
We have to be very
careful with this.
If this is not spent just
exactly, you can go to jail.
Go to jail?
The question.
I'm going to get
to the question.
I'm sorry.
So I said, well,
my children have
$100,000 tuition coming up.
Can we spend on that?
Oh, sure, no problem.
Is China ever going to allow
me to spend that money how
I would like to without
having to go to jail?
I mean, it's--
FRANK DIKOTTER: I will
give you my advice.
AUDIENCE: It's very daunting.
FRANK DIKOTTER:
For a $1,000 fee.
I don't think you'll go to jail.
But all these
billionaires in China
are a lot smarter than you
are because they grew up
in this system, and they
are desperate to get
their money out of the country.
So chances of you succeeding are
pretty slim, I'm sorry to say.
AUDIENCE: All right.
We have time for
one more question.
FRANK DIKOTTER: Now capital,
capitalism, free movement
of goods, people, not in China.
JAMES MILIUS: I want to thank
you again for coming out here
tonight.
So you've spoken a lot about the
ways in which Mao took things
from Stalin's ideology and
Stalin's implementation
of policies.
However, I know
that those who are
sympathetic to Mao or
to the Chinese system
would be quick to point out
differences between what
Mao and Stalin did, and would
point out that they often
disagreed on certain things.
I was wondering
if maybe you could
speak a little bit
towards to what extent
some of those differences
might be substantial,
and to what extent
they are superficial.
FRANK DIKOTTER: You
want another lecture?
I'm happy to give you one.
I talked briefly about how Mao
destroyed every organization
outside of the organization of
the Communist Party of China.
What do you think Adolf
Hitler did after 1933?
Here's your German word
of the day, [GERMAN],,
a process of
synchronization in which
the Nazis, over the course
of two, three years,
take over every
single institution
down to your local sports club.
Now all culture is
eliminated and replaced
with Nazi paraphernalia.
Where did he get it from?
He got it from Lenin.
Lenin was the
first one to do it.
Ultimately, of course,
these are different.
The Mao of 1949 is
not the Mao of 1956.
The differences between Mao
and Stalin are plentiful.
You can find all
sorts of differences.
But to emphasize difference is
to not see the overall picture.
The overall picture, I think,
is reasonably straightforward.
In the 20th century, you have
two trends that are opposed.
One is to separate out powers.
Goes back to that French
chap, Montesquieu.
You do philosophy?
That's what I thought.
And sociology.
Tough.
Montesquieu first
came up with the idea
of separation of powers.
Other philosophers did so, too.
For centuries in parts
of Europe, United
States, other
parts of the world,
people have been working
very hard at coming up
with checks and balances, an
independent judicial system,
complicated arrangements.
But sometimes you
have to hire a lawyer.
Can Boris Johnson
do this or that?
You need lawyers.
Difficult. Not sure.
You might end up in jail.
It's a great achievement,
an extraordinary achievement
for any government-- seen
from the Stone Age onwards,
where human beings
club each other--
for all of a sudden
the government
to respect a court order is
an extraordinary achievement.
That's one trend.
The other trend is the
concentration of power.
With Lenin, with Hitler,
Mussolini, you name it,
these dictators think that all
that wishy-washy separation
of powers only weakens
the entire entity.
What you ought to do
is concentrate powers
in the hands of one party
represented by one person.
So yes, I could go
on about differences
between Stalin and Mao.
But ultimately, it's
the same mechanism.
It's the same vision.
It's the same desire to control
power and keep it firmly
in the hands of the party state.
I'd say one difference
is that Stalin,
at the height of the
terror in the 1930s,
at least had the courage to
sign all the death warrants.
There were about
1.5 million of them.
He had to sign these long
books with lists of names.
He signed it.
Mao pitted people
against each other.
He made sure everybody
had blood on their hands.
But it's a minor detail.
Ultimately, it's
the one party state
that is barely different
from the beginning
of the century to the very end.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you, Dr. Dikotter.
FRANK DIKOTTER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]